phil is with us in michigan i feel
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show thank
you Dave nice to talk with you man I
kind of feel like I know you listening
to your podcast and and well you're
doing today right you giving everybody
you do is just me all right
how can I help so I just put in a
nutshell I'm self-employed
so my income varies from year to year
sure so it's very difficult I'm in sales
so I get a commission and very difficult
to budget we've been doing great we have
everything paid off my wife and I except
for our home we owe $80,000 on our house
and our house payments only like 400
bucks a month we go I got a smokin good
interest rate when when the market was
right so however recently like two years
ago she developed what's called a
cerebral on a fluid leak and so she
hasn't worked for over two years
now she does have we went through the
whole process she has an incredible
employer and actually as of right now
she's actually still on the books as
being employed which I just think is a
blessing from God that they would go two
years and keep her job for her but so
she's gotten short-term disability and
long-term disability we are now in the
process of applying for Social Security
disability but the issue is she's 34
years old and that's very difficult to
get even though it's supposed to go on
her function they kind of look at her
age and and it's kind of difficult to
get the government to want to pay for
for something that long yeah so other
questions that I have to do is number
one what's what's a good idea to try to
have some sort of a consistent budget
and then number two I've got probably
about $20,000 in in investments with
this this investor guy of ours he's a he
walk management investor and he invests
in neutral funds
all these different things but basically
what he does is he coordinates my with
my life insurance policy he coordinates
with my tax lady he coordinates with any
legal issue that I've got going on or
any got a daughter who's a sophomore in
college so we tell him that we're gonna
maybe have a wedding coming up and
hopefully never but we want to be able
to put some money towards that wedding
and he just kind of coordinates all of
those things for us we had probably
around 40,000 but in the last couple of
years we've taken out 20,000 of it just
to help pay for her medical bills we've
been very healthy so we've always know
what should we reveal and how do I we
save for retirement and how do I get a
budget that's with a fluctuating income
okay so what was that what should run in
the last five years what was your best
year of income and your worst year of
income ah best year of income would have
been probably 260 and the worst year
would have been 40 you really made
$40,000 yeah okay what happened
so as a distributor I have different
product lines I sell to doctors and
hospitals what happened and when those I
lost some of those product lines they
sold to other companies or I'm unable to
carry them though how long how often
does that kind of thing happen I have 12
different product lines so it's
basically happening all the time but I
also have other product lines to pick up
the slack and well two years ago when
this whole thing started with my wife we
just had a mass exodus of product lines
so that's where that was my worst year
okay well I mean so well what what I
would do is just monthly look into the
future for one month and say what is my
worst case scenario in the coming 30
days
and that that's you know that we can
predict fairly accurately and you say
you know my worst case scenario in the
coming 30 days is 15,000 probably going
to be more like 25 but my worst case is
15 okay whatever the number is I'm just
making that up
based on their worst case you rent that
you run down a normal budget in other
words you take your worst case say in
the coming 30 days I can accurately
predict that I'm absolutely gonna have
$12,000 $15,000 whatever it is sounds
like that number is realistic in your
situation then in that case you would do
a regular budget as if you were on
salary for that amount for this coming
30 days then you in addition to that you
make a list of other things that you
want to do or need to do that did not
make the cut
in that first round those I'd like to
build this emergency fund up I'd like to
do some more retirement money I'd like
to do this or that I'd like to set aside
some money for a wedding I'd like to do
whatever and then in any additional
money and then you make a list of the
things that didn't make the cut you
prioritize those and say the most
important one of these is number one the
second most important is number two the
third most important is number three and
then when money comes in above that
12,000 or that 15,000 you use that money
right down that list of priorities
number one gets all of it until it's
done number two gets all of it until
it's done and so will you say $12,000
was our baseline we did a budget on
$12,000 and we ended up making 18,000 so
you got another 6,000 and you go down
that list from 1 to whatever until you
use up the 6000 and that's called a
prioritized spending plan that's a form
the irregular income planning sheet is a
form in the back of the financial piece
materials or in the back of the Total
Money Makeover book it's all over the
place online it's a form we developed
years ago now sometimes people use the
every dollar budget and what they do is
they just reset their budget as they're
in
come comes in above their baseline but
they set the initial thing up as a
baseline and then if they get that extra
6000 and they just make adjustments in
there every dollar app to get on through
and to make that happen so hey good
question thank you for joining us